Rock and Roll Hall of Fame so we're you
know we were talking about it and stuff
we play a little clip you're doing
Woodstock which I never heard you do
before you just start performing that
that was the first time yeah you were
doing a hell of a number there that was
really good now that that was fun that
was good to do you know it's a it's been
in the back of my mind for a long time
that song I know it from from Joanie
from crosby Stills and Nash so I was I
guess I've been sort of putting it
together in the back of my head I think
people overlook your guitar playing
because it was really cool what you're
doing with the guitar starts going down
and James's voice starts going up I
don't know what you call that but it
just was really term for it no no I mean
the arrangement is really good the
musical arrangements real good on that
now you didn't put that out on the new
album did you know that that was too
late too late to do this so this would
be an exclusive version if you will it
in a sense yes in a sense yes would you
do that for us now I would you would you
would be honored to tell me we'll do a
little sound check here now listen to
this I can set you up with these
microphones play a little something on
you can talk for a second let's put this
mic down here and that one there all
right if you like that really happen I
could do that closer to where he's
playing my little echo well you like
this thing yeah look at some courtesy
echo that's do you hear oh yeah or is
that on me no that's good - you're on
you're in there - I think are you
singing oh no you're in the same old oil
drama or whatever it is yeah do you like
the mix between the guitar in your voice
yeah I can't kind of do it let me see
but I came apart child of God he was
walking along the road and I asked them
so where are you going this he told me
well I'm going down yes curse farm gonna
join a rock and roll band Oh get down
all the land try to set my soul free
we are Stardust we are golden
we are million-year-old carbon we've got
to get ourselves back to the garden well
then can I walk beside you
I've come to lose my small and maybe
it's a car is something turning
[Music]
maybe it's the time of the year
[Music]
and maybe it's the type of man and I
don't know who I
life is for learning
we are Stardust golden we are million
year old carbon and we've got to get
ourselves back to the garden by the time
we got to Woodstock we are half a
million strong and everywhere was a song
and a celebration
[Applause]
and I dreamed I saw the bonded ships
flying shotgun in the skies turning it
the flies above our mission
we are Stardust we are golden we are
caught up in the devil's bargain and we
got to get ourselves
back to the garden
[Applause]
we are Stardust we are golden
they are million year old carbon and
we've got to get our Sam back to the
[Music]